magnus what a day it was for you plus
five every game decisive what clicked
i don't know really i mean i felt felt
like my play was pretty shaky throughout
most of the day um
but uh yeah i mean i i won a bunch of
these very like nervy time trouble
duels where nobody really knew what was
going on so uh i guess overall you know
uh
i um
while in the rapid i think i could have
scored more today i had um
uh probably scored a little more than i
should have you mentioned that in the
rapid you had a little bit of issue with
time management but it seems that now
that both sides started in time pressure
you were the one that was able to
navigate better when the seconds came
down ticking
yeah i guess navigate better is the the
operate word i i don't necessarily think
i always navigated it so well but um i
felt like i was always
one step a step ahead of my my opponents
in those situations but yeah it was it
was a crazy day really i mean
um
not
one that i'm like massively proud of but
it's so i'm not proud of you no but it's
fine it's still it's still
pretty cool to have played no no draws
at all no draws
i don't think you've ever done this at
least not in a gct where you went a full
day without a draw no i don't think so
uh i had one day in leuven i think where
i won seven games and one draw and one
loss i think so at least uh is that
slightly better or slightly worse no i
mean that's obviously obviously a little
bit worse but um
now this was um yeah i don't
think i've ever done anything
quite like that i mean i've had days in
the world blitz like last year where i
lost like three games but i won a bunch
as well
but i don't think i made a couple of
draws at the end uh yeah it's really
it's really uh
pretty pretty unusual and uh
it's not the kind of way that i pride
myself on playing but it's
i guess pretty good entertainment so i
shouldn't complain you started the day
off against jordan van forest a point
behind and you immediately caught up
didn't step off the gas did you feel
very motivated to beat him in the first
round yeah i mean i did
catch up but then i lost two games in a
row and came
in rounds three and four so didn't last
very long but
um i mean once i saw the pairing
i thought i should try and try and win
the first game
which wasn't the game wasn't great but i
was always like trying to keep a lot of
pieces on the board and make him make
him think and finally he made a few
mistakes if you have to choose one thing
that you want to improve tomorrow
compared to today what would it be i
mean i hope that i will not lose like an
idiot to wesley again
well big hopes there for magnus carlos
and tomorrow the world champion leader
of our tournament here at the grand
chess tour in zagreb one day to go guys
back in the studio we'll have more
interviews with you soon
thank you alejandro everyone has their
goals miro and these are our standings
after nine